when the trailer for The Phantom Menace
dropped fans were so hyped that they
bought tickets to other movies just to
see the trailer not even staying for the
movie afterwards all through November
1998 theaters sold out tickets to films
Like A Bug's Life only to have seats
empty out before the opening titles even
rolled Star Wars was back despite how
the end product turned out the phantom
menace trailer was damn good the opening
shot of a fog covered swamp with the
force theme playing is still spine
tingling all the visuals look awesome
and even the a Yoda lines feel epic it's
so good that it almost makes us want to
go back and watch episode 1 again almost
nobody needs to be reminded of how the
movie actually turned out by now it's
achieved meme status as a symbol for
incredible disappointment now this is
POD
Ray